[Music]
punta salinas beach
is just an hour's drive from the
dominican capital
it's a kitesurfer's paradise offering
perfect conditions
this is one of the best places for this
sport in the whole of the dominican
republic
the waves aren't too big the wind speed
is normally between 8 and 32 knots it
almost never
rains and the sun is always shining
[Music]
gerando terrero has been coming here for
20 years
but now his kitesurfing paradise has a
problem
in the past you wouldn't find a single
plastic bag in the water
now there's suddenly a lot more plastic
here
so eddie rosado has been called in to
help
he works for the united nations
environment program
part of his work aims to improve the
management of plastic waste
becoming a completely plastic free
country is difficult
but what we can do is make our tourism
industry more sustainable
and manage the waste that's generated
more effectively
is involved in a project for the
international climate initiative
which aims to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions in the tourism industry
improving waste management is a key part
of that
the waste in punta salinas is mainly
caused by local tourism
visitors are not clearing up after
themselves
we have aluminum cans plastic bags
visitors bring stuff to the beach and
then leave it here
they don't feel responsible
he says many people here don't realize
how harmful plastic is for the
environment
both consumers and food manufacturers
see it as hugely practical
manufacturers saw so many advantages in
plastic that at some stage we lost sight
of the whole issue of sustainability
and the public weren't given enough
information on the importance of
disposing of plastic waste properly
[Music]
but it's not just the population of 10
million that isn't disposing of waste
properly
the authorities are also overwhelmed by
the problem as becomes clear further
inland
this is one of the more than 350 illegal
dumps in the dominican republic
it's completely unorganized the waste
just piles up
in sharp contrast to the beautiful
images that the country is known for
all over the world
punta cana on the eastern tip of the
island is a paradise
after a year with very few visitors the
tourists are now back
in greater numbers than usual in july
bookings were up 10 compared with the
same period two years ago
here the beaches are pristine the big
hotel chains can't afford
to have tourists put off by waste
most visitors stay in the big
all-inclusive resorts
all inclusive tourism makes our battle
against single-use plastic easier
because the tourists don't leave the
resort
but at the same time there are other
aspects that are problematic
such as the sheer amount of waste
generated the region of punta cana alone
produces 500 tons of garbage each day
felipe beltran runs a waste collection
business
he's working with eddie rosado to make
the hotels more sustainable
tourists in the all-inclusive hotels
consume more than usual
and that in turn generates more waste
but on the other hand the hotels are
well organized and that's often helpful
in a backyard well hidden from the
guests he and his team pick up the
garbage
we are only allowed to film if we don't
show the name of the hotel
none of the businesses here want to be
linked with the issue of waste
felipe beltran's company sorts through
10 tons of garbage each day
it's then sold on to recycling centers
or exported
this private waste management system is
expensive and the state provides
no assistance the hotels pay for
everything
doing something well is always more
expensive than doing it badly
but we need to think of the future by
being sustainable
we can safeguard the future of tourism
that's exactly why many hotels are being
proactive
and tackling the problem of waste the
state doesn't oblige them to take action
the resort dreams la romana in the town
of bayahebe
has been working for years to reduce
plastic waste
when we first started keeping a record
in 2017
we were getting through two million
drinking straws a year just in the
hotels here in the dominican republic
solar maintenance
drinks are now served without straws and
the luxury resort has managed to
eliminate nearly all
single-use plastic but one problem
remains
water is only available in plastic
bottles that's standard across the
country
other solutions just never caught on
an average all-inclusive resort in punta
cana with 1 000 beds
gets through 1.2 million plastic models
a year
we've achieved a lot but we still have a
way to go to eliminate plastic
completely
[Music]
the aim is to remove all single-use
plastic from the country's tourist
resorts
a goal shared by eddie rosado
it's difficult but it is doable we just
need to find solutions that are
practical
and then monitor them to ensure they're
working but we can succeed
you